Alright, let's go next to our color from the
seven eight one area code.
Who is calling today from seven eight one
hi David.
This is Steven Alliance.
Can hear me?
Yes.
We're not on any kind of weird device speakerphone
or Bluetooth, right?
No, not right now.
Sorry about that.
Okay, no problem.
Go ahead.
So with Thanksgiving coming up, I know a lot
of us are going to be sitting down at the
table with people that we deeply love, but
who may hold beliefs that are kind of dangerous.
And I'm not just talking about, you know,
I'm on the left.
I'm not just talking about people who are
on the right.
I'm talking about people who are anti vacs,
who staunchly don't believe in climate change
in any capacity.
They don't just sort of have some nuanced
view on the scale or something.
How do you think we should approach those
people?
If you know, you do need to try and start
making ground on talking to some of them about
this stuff and informing them.
But if you make them feel cornered and insulted,
it's going to do a disservice to the things
you believe in because your beliefs will seem
farther out to them than they ever have.
Yup.
So here, here's my idea on this.
So here's the framework as I'm understanding
it from you.
Um, on the one hand, these are people you
don't want to ruin a relationship with.
You don't want to ruin Thanksgiving.
You don't want to be the Grinch that stole
Thanksgiving, so to speak, but at the same
time, you don't really feel good about just
avoiding, um, the dangerous beliefs that some
of these people have, whether they are anti-vaxxer
or whatever else.
So I think here's the happy medium and what
I recommend apply or employ, maybe better
said, um, a respectful, sort of Socratic method
of questioning, not about the facts per se,
but how the people came to believe what they
believe.
Checkout Anthony, Magna Boscos YouTube channel
where he does street epistemology for some
of the, the technique and maybe apply a little
more, um, soften it a little more because
it might be family or friends or whatever
the case may be.
And simply all you're trying to do is step
one at Thanksgiving.
Right?
You don't, you're not trying to argue all
the facts, but you want to get people to at
least question how they're coming to their
conclusions and start to respectfully inquire
about, that's interesting.
How long have you had that position?
How did you learn about it?
Where did you learn about it?
Is that a source that you've determined is
trustworthy?
How do you determine that a source is trust?
Trustworthy.
Most people will very quickly realize that
the foundation upon which their beliefs are
built is not nearly as strong as they believe.
And it's just step one, you know, and then
maybe it Hanukkah or Christmas, then you go
to step two or whatever the case may be.
Okay.
Thanks for that insight, David.
Yeah.
All right.
Very good.
Okay, great to hear from you.
Uh, short and sweet.
I like it.
L